in alpha tool I don't know I think one
year for abandoning [ __ ] is just
appalling absolutely appalling I think
for the families of those people who
died 10 years will not seem enough but I
wondered if the judges pitched for 10
years so that there wouldn't be an
appeal because if you've got 26 years I
think certainly hit of in this country
there would have been perhaps more
grounds for appeal but on the whole
probably not enough I don't think it's
enough when more than 4,000 people's
lives were affected either dramatically
that night as we know is one of the last
on the boat off when he was many hours
before fell into his life boat or
something as he said initially I think
that 44,000 people have been affected
either at the time quite dramatically
and subsequently many with nightmares
with the inability to go on any boats at
all or any crowded spaces or anything
like that so it's not just the 33 that
unfortunately had died but it was the
whole mismanagement of it in indeed and
we've heard the captain earlier on in
the trial talking about the fact that he
felt he'd been through the media meat
grinder that he'd been under a lot of
stress since then but as you say for the
families of those who lost their lives
and indeed survivors as well we've all
been through it but he caused it and he
does need to take responsibility for
that
for firstly causing the shipwreck and
for not evacuating quickly enough and as
a ship captain abandoning the ship
dereliction of duty it's quite gross
gross negligence yeah the other thing is
that there were quite a lot on the
bridge at the time many of them who were
called to court account for this did a
plea bargain with I don't think any any
sentences involved but if you've got 13
professionals driving with his rival
most incredibly large vessel as
and you think there was more than one
person more than just the captain that
was negligent so